[Musique]
cinquante personnes rénove chaque samedi
les différentes pièces de la collection
du musée les transports pour que le
dimanche tout soit prêt pour la visite
[Musique]
ce cadran compteur servait à compter le
nombre de voyageurs monter dans
l'omnibus voyageurs montant à
l'intérieur ou voyageur montant à
l'impérial le receveur se tenait debout
sur le marche-pied l'accès à l'impérial
s'effectuer par une échelle ce véhicule
date de 1863
c'est la plus ancienne pièce de notre
collection un peu plus tard en 1879 des
omnibus un peu plus modernes ont été mis
en service à paris par la compagnie
générale des omnibus l'accès à
l'impérial s'effectuer par un escalier c
onimus bien connu sur les lignes
madeleine bastille une wagram bastille
ont roulé jusqu'à la guerre de 1914 dans
votre musée vous avez également des
machines à vapeur
nous avons un certain nombre de machines
à vapeur particulièrement
caractéristique de nos anciens chemins
de fer d'intérêt local
vous savez en effet que lorsque le
réseau d'intérêt général a été terminée
vers 1880 l'état a confié au département
le soin de construire un certain nombre
de lignes d'intérêt local pour compléter
le réseau d'intérêt général alors nous
avons récupéré par conséquent les
véhicules de plus caractéristiques de
ces chemins de fer d'intérêt local
nous avons une machine des tramways de
la corrèze mise en service en 1914 c'est
déjà de machines assez imposante et nous
avons surtout ce véhicule qui est assez
intéressant c'est une machine qui est
très ancienne elle date de 1881
elle a été mise en service sur les
lignes du département de la loire et
c'est une machine légère 12 tonnes
seulement qui est maintenant
tout à fait unique en son genre il a
également l'attraction entre pied
représenté dans votre musée nous avons
bien sûr la traction électrique nous
sommes ici dans un tramway de genève et
datent de 1900 travaux et à plateforme
ouverte bien sympathique d'ailleurs qui
fonctionne qui fonctionne bien entendu
pas le voir allons être le courant
depuis 1900 il et il a déjà fonctionné
oui bien sûr et nous faisons de temps en
temps au marché notre matériel nasa le
verrouille c'est excellent
quels sont les autres tramways dans
votre nous avons un pratiquement des
travaux et de toutes les villes de
france et nous avons particulier un
tramway parisien trois bris standard de
paris et a fonctionné sur la ligne rouge
gare de l'est qui date de 1924 est
également excellent état partout
collection que la martre les jours la
connexion on peut la voir le dimanche le
musée est ouvert le dimanche après-midi
au public depuis longtemps notre musée
s'est constitué en 1957
il ya une douzaine d'années mais le
musée une 0 but depuis quatre enfants
dans cet ancien des côtes propre et qui
était bien notre mission
avant are my ra d'été est le but de
votre association eh bien nous voulons
constituer enfants s'amusaient des
transports urbains analogue à ses musées
des transports urbains qui sont si
nombreux à l'étranger
eh bien je remercie tenez prouver
décembre
[Musique]